[Music]
welcome everyone to geek culture's
humble abode so today is a very special
day as we have said to bring you
something really really cool to show off
to you guys ahead of time so you can
recognize all these fellas on the table
we have alloy here we got the thunderjaw
here you got tiny watcher there so if
you know who these are then you
definitely know that horizon forbidden
west is coming out real soon on february
18th so this is the old collector's
edition statue the a law that came with
the collector's edition now of course
with the new game coming up we're going
to show you something even more awesome
which is the regala edition and the
collector's edition for for horizon
forbidden west instead of just me
rambling on about this i'm going to
bring on a fellow super fan to show the
things off and welcome victoria thank
you
yeah so together we're going to show off
what's inside the collector's edition as
well as the regard edition so let's get
to it please pass us the box please
we're going to start with the
collector's edition first me and
victoria we had the pleasure of trying
out the game we
love it love it absolutely love it still
a fan i was not disappointed yeah so if
you don't know about the series it's
basically about post-apocalyptic future
where machines overran the earth and
humanity starts all over again
and alloy or heroin
basically is saving the wall and this
time she's back to save the world again
yeah she's got a lot of pressure on her
shoulders exactly and i think that's
what the game is about too so go ahead
victoria unbox the collector's edition
oh my god i'm so excited
i was looking at this for a really long
time
um and i because i'm so indecisive i
ended up not getting it yet
it's just the correct way okay i'm so
worried about screwing up the box
you know what
just do it no no no no no no no no no no
no no rip it up a true fan would be
careful
it takes two
wrong games
what you guys do all the time this is so
glorious
[Music]
there we go so have you guys take a look
at the good box look at the art
so this is similar to i think the key
art for the game as well as what you'll
see on your playstation 5 home screen ah
that's so cool wow so as you can see
here we have the treble task
so we're gonna put it together i think
okay let's let's get it out of its
plastic prison
here we go there you go
hello welcome to the world
so if you didn't know the tremendous is
one of the machines that you'll meet in
the game so just like horizon zero dawn
you can tear parts of it like this
useful task here oh it's little eloy
got her in here
wow i i love her so much so how does
eloy compare to what viktor is wearing
which is
also a horizon zero dawn inspired hoodie
same same same same but different none
of you have had the chance to play the
game yet so we're not gonna go into two
deep spoilers but uh like i mentioned
eli is gonna save the world again so
gonna meet new people and obviously
there's a new focus on alloy and uh her
evolving personality
right yes
okay i think
it's the wrong place
i was just trying to get it to fit
it's way tougher than actually fighting
the real treble task that's what i'm
gonna say
so if i had my focus on where where are
the weak points we're going to look at
these two cannons here where it's going
to get you if i if i remember correct
plasma shots
oh right then you got the four tasks
over here that we painstakingly attached
onto this tremendous you can remove that
for some valuable resources as well
with some launchers at the back and then
the ammo drums
and of course every other part that is
not covered by armor which based on this
there's not many parts they are not
covered by armor indeed man the details
on this is amazing though yeah it's
particularly like the base the way that
they have painted the base to suit that
snowy vibe that we have in some other
areas in horizon forbidden west right
here hiding beneath this drawer we're
just gonna pull it out so you can have a
look and show it to the camera
okay
oh look at this
of course i think if you are just
playing the game
try not to read too much in the art book
surely there's gonna be spoilers there
wow okay wow
oh okay
okay i'm gonna stop looking i'm gonna
start looking i'm gonna stop looking but
uh this is really nice the quality of
the book is it's just really nice
display case for the game
unless you buy a digital and it's just
going to be ta-da
[Laughter]
so you get a bunch of codes okay so you
get i do that again
so for the codes this time without the
actual alphabets and letters yes we got
the nora legacy outfit and you know
legacy spear here get some extras in
photo mode
got some dlc's we got machine strike
piece resource pack digital soundtrack
oh yeah so if you don't know yet um
horizon forbidden west has introduced a
lot more elements that weren't in the
first game that includes a board game
in-game so that's what the strike pieces
are all about okay we're done with the
traumatize the collector's edition for
horizon forbidden west we're gonna go
straight into the regala edition instead
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
circle lectures especially the all-new
2022 titan evo with its revamped 4-way
lumbar system for enhanced back support
if pu leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all-new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely frost blue the
tyson evo is even magnetized along the
hit pillow to stick on the headrest of
course there are even more new features
so do check them out at secretlab.co
and there you have it this is the regala
edition we have a lot of stuff here in
this gigante box it has some really nice
art
we got the regular tremendous right in
front and if the back here is really
cool we're gonna flip this nicely
yep
so regala is one of those rebels that
you'll be going up against so i know
that you met her it's played by angela
bassett
and she really really is quite menacing
yes yay
wow this box is so cool too it's got
more claws riders
so again this is that
kia that you find on the book
it looks really really good that's the
box itself it's different different
scenery than the other box
you know there's more like red blight a
lot more of the um
i guess the west the forbidden west yep
oh
right
wow
a lot more color is going on here with
all the it's so big
so it's
helping you set the scene for your own
personal diorama at home
it's really really nice some tribal art
here all right
this is a big boy it is a big boy
that is definitely what a lois said just
pull that drawer open to see what
goodies like it is uh what we saw
earlier there's some extra pieces though
there is yeah so in addition to the art
book as well as the steel book that you
guys have seen
previously there's even more goodies in
the regala edition hidden underneath
the cardboard how'd you know that
i don't know you know inside the
information wow
from aloy oh it's a focus
so you can complete your dream of being
aloy with a wearable focus
it comes with a stand as well so there
you go so you can display your focus
what do you see
what do you see in our office where are
we points i can see under all of your
clothes right now and it's very awkward
we mentioned earlier
we're gonna be playing some machine
strike in the game
what five-year-old made this
dude i just kidding this is nice it's
probably made like a venue
it's a replica sun wing and a porsche
rider so this is the course rider that
you can get in game and outside of this
is quite cool though uh two up playing
cards
perfect the ink to add to any collection
and then
just like the first game
you can get yourself a nice map
of the forbidden west
this is cool
right nice you get to do this again all
right this time hopefully we can do it
with less trouble okay
there's a little tab oh it lights up
this is a little battery tab here i
think it lights up yeah it does okay so
we're gonna take a look at what
the regala edition of the traumatized
looks like when it's lightened up later
i think this goes here
oh
even the tusks are different
oh and these are um posable
which the other one isn't so that's
pretty cool so this is a little bit
different
the previous one was just grooves where
you just
kind of push it in
these are like little balls joints ball
joints yeah so you can move them around
uh like victoria said it's poseable
look at the trunk do the wave pretty
cool okay so aloy that you get in the
regular edition is the same one as the
collector's edition so obviously this
tremendous has a lot more color on it
it's more
in line with the tribe that has taken
control of it which is regardless rebels
as you can see this hut on its back so
in the game you're going to be fighting
against these rebels and
knowing that they have the tremortals on
the other side you're going to have a
little bit tougher time i don't know
about you i hate fighting the humans in
the game me too i just enjoy killing the
machines so it's called
victoria hates humans and machines i
love machines i love uh you know that's
why like getting taking over the
cauldrons is really important because i
really like
i'm
controlling
the
machines
context that really doesn't sound good
on your part
then you only like machines
gosh there's so much i feel like all
right guys probably be the last video
that you see me
on in i don't know
it is definitely harder to put this
together than defeating the german test
in the game
it's because it's um the joint cereal
joint yeah and it's in it it's
you can move it which is cool there we
go
all right
there you go
you're gonna put this on could you help
me lift it up
as much as i don't like the humans the
design of things
it's very cool
yeah alma is really nice
good morning details yeah i would say
most of the detail in the coloring is
really focused on the machine and the
terrain anyway so it's not even the
focus which is
pretty great
the focus oh yes the focus okay so the
base is about the same the same snowy
terrain so really you're looking at
differences the paint job for the
traumatized as well as this additional
hut
which kind of reminds me a lot of the
rings
if you know what i mean unfortunately
you can't slide down the trunk with a
like a certain elf that we know but uh
it's still fun to fight against this um
it's cooler than legolas oh wow fighting
what's that said it man this is why i
love this game there's one more thing
right let's remove that battery oh yeah
i think
oh here oh there you go
and it looks really good though i feel
like we should turn off all the lights
here you go he's alive i can hear the
sounds like the sound effects in horizon
both games is what makes it so give me
your best traumatized impression
i don't know what they sound like i
haven't encountered that but uh yeah the
sound effects in the game
is
also why the machines are so cool or
taking down the machines they're so cool
yep so obviously with the lights
it adds another layer to this tremotus
if i'm not wrong it turns them off
automatically after five minutes
right so if you want to show off when
someone comes over you can show them
your cool collection for five minutes
yeah for five minutes yeah this is a
pretty cool showpiece i mean like it was
saying originally i like that cleaner
look
for the
i thought i would have preferred the
collector's edition but this is pretty
epic
right this is this is definitely worth
it
so if you have bought or pre-ordered
these beauties i would say this is what
you have to look forward to and uh just
to you know
keep things interesting
i mentioned earlier that victoria is
going to fight me for ownership of one
of these
collectors edition slash regular edition
yep so we're just going to do it right
here right now right now it's not going
to be a separate episode of us no this
is just going to be rock paper scissors
if you win you get to take it back so
the stack sticks are quite high oh okay
okay okay oh i know what you want and
i'm not gonna give it to you oh that's
okay okay okay okay okay okay rock paper
scissors
oh man rock paper scissors
rock paper scissors
oh
we should
you know this is just a joke she's not
getting any of this but
thanks to our good friends at
playstation asia
victoria you and your team at sub nerd
are gonna receive the collector's
edition
of
horizon forbidden world oh my god i'm
gonna leave you to the stage to express
your joy now i'd like to thank my mother
and playstation and of course you guys
are geek culture thank you so much
i'm so i'm so excited thank you thank
you give you guys a good look at the
regular edition as well as the
collector's edition so if you
pre-ordered these uh babies you're gonna
have them soon when the game releases on
february 18th
um and then you know if you have any
questions about all these figures or the
additional stuff that comes with the
additions please drop them in the
comments below and we'll answer them
when we can sora is gonna
go ham over her collector's edition oh
yeah so i'm going to take this
regardless edition and
disappear
and she can have her time with the
collector's edition i see i like how he
took it so i can't take pho
thank you so much
[Music]
you